Next question is part of my continued effort to stay in remission from a variant cancer. I've decided to have my mercury fillings removed. Good idea. Unfortunately, I have several of them.
Yeah, most people do. I saw a biological dentist today.
And sure of you, they were happy to hear I was working with cutters clinic and asked me to ask you if there's anything they need to know about my treatment before start removing them replacing the silver fillings.
So when you have your mercury fillings removed, you want to do what this person is doing. You want to go to a biological dentist to do that because they will use a mercury vapor vacuum.
They will ask you, they will do different suction techniques and they will use a rubber dam so that they're not spilling any.
When they're drilling it out, they're gasifying the mercury and that's the most damaging part. If you're breathing that in, you're just poisoning yourself. So, but getting that out is super, super important.
So, now we don't recommend people getting their silver fillings removed when they're in the throes of cancer because it can, you know, you then you're having to deal with detoxifying the silver mercury at the same time.
So once you're in this point to feel like in a relative state of remission, maybe it's time to work on these other things. That's what this person is doing.
So what else should you do? So when you know you're going to go and get your mercury fillings out a couple of things. So you want to be adding binders. So if you have not looked at the seven phases of detoxification.
Information. The course is one thing. That's a good thing to look at. But whenever I don't have you have, I don't have a way to give you access to that course, but let me pull up a blog post because I did a blog post summary of my book, the seven phases of detoxification.
So let me get to that and I'll show you what that is.
And I made a video on it. So here's the blog post.
And just all you can do is go to the blog section right there. Look, just start typing in detoxification or the seven phases of detoxification. There's multiple blog posts on that.
What I want you to look at is you need to be binding stuff in the gut. So you need to make sure that phase six that you're eliminating properly in a regular basis. Yes, I am. Are you doing copy animals. Yes, I am.
Great. So that will help with phase one and two and three that will help with phase six.
Phase five of detoxification is binding stuff in the gut. So you want to make sure that you're taking a binder.
So in that I list on that blog post I list some really good binders.
And then you want to make sure that then that you're also starting to use a key later. Now, if you have seven mercury fillings that they're going to take out over the course of six months, then it's a little bit more difficult to recommend that key later.
Right away, because if you're going to take a long time of getting these out, we don't want to use a key later to pull that is pulling stuff out of the of the fillings that are remaining in your mouth.
Well, I would recommend what's called phase zero assist phase zero assist is is I think the better of all our binders. We also have key la clear.
That's a great binder. One of those two, excuse me, both of those are key laders. Those are both good key laders to take the only one of those.
Touch base with us so we can make some recommendations for you specifically because I don't know who is that's asking this question.
So when you're going to get your fillings out, you want to make sure that all your phases of detoxification are open.
So if you do no idea what I'm talking about, go back to the blog, look up phases of detoxification.
There's multiple blog posts on it. Several of them have my video that explained the seven phases of detoxification.
You can download the seven phases of detoxification book, at least part of the book on our website for free.
And soon I'll give everybody that our locations access to the seven phases of detoxification course that goes through that.
But when you're detoxing heavy metals, because you're going to liberate them through a pulley them out of the body with a biological dentist.
You want to make sure you're binding them and they got so you're not reabsorbing them.
And that's your key lady that out of the blood. So you're getting them out of the blood so that I just transferred to another seven.